can i ask you a difficult question
sure there is popularity
in martyrdom there's popularity
in pointing out that the empire has no
clothes
that that can become a drug in itself
i've confronted this in scientific work
i've done at mit
where there are certain things that are
not done well people are not being the
best version of themselves
and particular aspects
of a particular field
are in need of a revolution and part of
me
wanted to point that out versus
doing the hard work of
publishing papers and doing the
revolution basically just pointing out
look
you guys are doing it wrong and then
just walking away
are you aware of the drug of martyrdom
of uh the
the ego involved in it that it can cloud
your thinking
probably one of the best questions i've
ever been asked um
so let me let me try to sort it out
first of all we are all mysteries to
ourself
at some level so it's possible there's
stuff going on
in me that i'm not aware of that's
driving but in general i would say one
of my better
strengths is that i'm not especially ego
driven
i have an ego i clearly think highly of
myself
but it is not driving me i do not crave
that kind of validation
i do crave certain things i do love a
good
eureka moment there is something great
about it and there's something even
better about the phone calls you make
next when you share it
right it's pretty it's pretty fun right
i really like it
i also really like my subject
right there's something about a walk in
the forest when
you have a tool kit in which you can
actually look at creatures and see
something
deep right i like it that drives me
and i could entertain myself for the
rest of my life right if i
if i was somehow isolated from the rest
of the world but i was in a place that
was biologically interesting
you know hopefully i would be with
people that i love
and pets that i love believe it or not
but
you know if i were in that situation and
i could just go out every day
and look at cool stuff and figure out
what it means i could be all right with
that
so i'm not heavily driven by the
um the ego thing as you put it so i
i i'm completely the same except
instead of the pets i would put robots
but so it's not
it's the eureka it's the exploration of
of the subject that brings you joy and
fulfillment it's not the ego
well there's there's more to say no i
really don't think it's the ego thing
um i will say i also have kind of a
secondary passion for
robot stuff i've never made anything
useful
but i do believe i believe i found my
calling
but if this wasn't my calling my calling
would have been inventing stuff i really
i really enjoy that too so i get what
you're saying about the analogy
quite quite well um as far as the
martyrdom thing
i i understand the drug you're talking
about and i've seen it
more than i felt it i do if i'm just to
be completely candid
and that this question is so good it
deserves a candid answer
i do like the fight
right i like fighting against people i
don't respect and i like winning
but i have no interest in martyrdom
one of the reasons i have no interest in
martyrdom is that i'm having too good a
time
right i very much enjoy my life and
such a good answer i have a wonderful
wife i have
amazing children i live in a lovely
place
i don't want to exit any quicker than i
have to
that said i also believe in things and a
willingness to exit if that's the only
way is not exactly inviting martyrdom
but it is an acceptance that
fighting is dangerous and going up
against powerful forces
means who knows what will come of it
right i don't have the sense
that the thing is out there that used to
kill inconvenient people i don't think
that's how it's done anymore it's
primarily done through
destroying them reputationally which is
not something i
relish the possibility of but there is a
difference between
a willingness to face the hazard
rather than a desire to face it
because of the thrill right for me the
thrill is in
um fighting when i'm in the right
i've i think i feel that that is a
worthwhile way to take
what i see as the the kind of brutality
that is
built into men and to channel it to
something
useful right if it is not channeled into
something useful it will be channeled
into something else so it damn well
better be channeled into something
useful
it's not motivated by fame and
popularity those kinds of things
it's the they're you know you know
you're just making me realize that
enjoying the fight
fighting the powerful an idea that you
believe is right
is a kind of um
it's a kind of optimism for the human
spirit it's like
we can win this it's almost like you're
turning into action into personal action
this hope for
for humanity by saying like we can win
this
uh and that makes you feel
good about like the rest of humanity
that if there's people like me then
we're going to be okay even if you're
like your ideas
might be wrong or not but if you believe
they're right
and you're fighting the powerful against
all odds
then we're going to be okay
that that to me if i were to project i
mean that because i enjoy the fight as
well
i think that's the way i that's what
brings me joy
is it's almost like uh it's optimism
um in action well it's a little
different for me
and again i think you know i uh i
recognize you you're familiar
your construction is familiar even if it
isn't mine right
um for me i actually expect us
not to be okay and i'm not okay with
that
but what's really important if i feel
like what i've said is i don't know of
any reason that it's too late
as far as i know we could still save
humanity and we could get to the fourth
frontier or something akin to it
but i expect us not to i expect us to
[ __ ] it up right
i don't like that thought but i've
looked into the abyss and i've
done my calculations and the number of
ways we could not
succeed are many and the number of ways
that we could manage to get out of this
very dangerous phase of history is small
but the thing i don't have to worry
about
is that i didn't do enough right
that i was a coward that i
you know prioritized other things
at the end of the day i think i will be
able to say to myself and in fact the
thing that allows me to sleep
is that when i saw clearly what needed
to be done
i tried to do it to the extent that it
was in my power and
you know if we fail as i expect us to
i can't say well geez that's on me
you know and you know frankly i regard
what i just said to you as something
like
a personality defect right i'm trying to
free myself
from the sense that this is my fault on
the other hand my guess is that
personality defect is probably
good for humanity right it's a good one
for me to have
it you know the externalities of it are
positive
so i don't feel too bad about it yeah
that's funny
so yeah our perspective on the world
are different but they rhyme like you
said because i i've also looked into the
abyss
and it kind of smiled nervously back
so i have uh i have a more optimistic
sense that we're gonna win more than
likely we're going to be okay
right there with you brother i'm hoping
you're right i'm expecting me to be
right
you